hierauf flex basierter basis einfach
ziert das dingen auf machen eine stadt
fahren wie wieder die leute gucken wenn
hier
ich habe etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir haben
heute was na ja ich sag mal so als ich
das zum ersten mal gesehen habe dass so
ein produkt existiert ich habe direkt
zugeschlagen und wollte das haben wir
haben hier ja hier drin wir können es
kurz hinter zu ist sogar diesmal nicht
vom tisch aber sieht so aus wir haben
hier eine smart watch mit ihr platz drin
also praktisch sachen kombiniert die ich
auf einem kanal in letzter zeit immer
häufiger mal thematisiert wird alex
herzog dagegen friedlich
das muss ich ja kaufen so eine smart
watch mit ihr posten next step von
apples smartphone schmidt airports drin
naja wir werden sehen ich muss sagen ich
weiß nicht mehr wie teuer das war weil
das so ewig gedauert hat bis das
angekommen ist also ich habe das
bestimmt vor über zweieinhalb monaten
nur so bestellt also das hat wirklich
extrem lang gedauert ich habe ja auch
schon in vielen videos gesagt das ist
zur zeit absolut katastrophal ist was
diese unboxing videos angepeilt alles
was international geschätzt wird dass
das dauert ewig und jetzt ist es mal
angekommen jetzt geht es auch wieder
schneller also ich hab jetzt letzte
woche auch noch ein paar sachen bestellt
die kommen jetzt wieder ganz normal an
nur ich habe auch sehr oft in den
kommentaren gelesen dass leute sachen
bestellt haben die nicht angekommen sind
und ich hatte das gleiche problem also
corona pipapo auf jeden fall ist dass
das gerät das steht da drauf smart
bracelet web tvs bluetooth 5.0 wir
öffnen das jetzt erst mal und dann sind
wir einmal zum arbeitsplatz und dann
zeige ich euch wie teuer das war und vor
allem was das alles für funktionen hat
und ob sich das lohnt
und das werden wir jetzt am
dieses videos noch mal gespannt ob das
ding noch akku hat weil wenn das jetzt
zweieinhalb monate unterwegs war okay
ist das paket ein coaching sind 289
shisha roth t shirt oder schuhe so sieht
das ganze aus wir haben hier die weit
kopfhörer die man in die smart watch
einfach reinpacken kann fungiert also
praktisch wie so ein airports lade case
denke ich mal
und hier haben wir dann noch einmal so
ein armband so ganz normal wenn man es
halt weil hier das smart watch kennt und
hier das ladekabel
was ist das denn kümmern das habe ich
noch nie gesehen so was da kann man
wahrscheinlich die uhr einfach drauf
stellen oder und dann lädt das das hier
ist der eigentliche computer
beziehungsweise die watch um dieses jahr
geht
und hier haben wir dann beim kopfhörer
die da also es ist alles schon ziemlich
minimal klein gehalten
wirst du jetzt einmal rüber und ich
zeige euch die ganzen funktionen die das
ding haben sollen wird getestet
okay leute um dieses produkt geht es an
premium smart watch a ha ich habe die
gal gibt es auch noch in rot ich habe
ihnen schwarz bestellt durch dieses foto
bin ich darauf aufmerksam geworden hier
sieht man diese ehe popstar drin also
die sind in der lodge anscheinend drin
die produkte sind ja immer in der video
schaltung verlinkt wir haben hier ein
fitness trecker sleeptracker messe
primacom einer push push push messe
chart track art also eigentlich so diese
standard gehalt hat jede smart watch
aber die airports da drin hat halt nicht
jede und deswegen finde ich es
eigentlich schon echt nice ok ich will
das unbedingt aus packen wir es wünschen
zurück so lädt herzlich willkommen
zurück
wir ziehen hier erstmal die folie ab und
ich vermute mal man kann das jetzt
irgendwie immer
man kann es hier auch klappen und kann
dann im kopfhörer hier einlegen
und ich glaube dann ist das hier
tatsächlich schon das display also und
meine akkus
was man aufpassen dass das nicht
rausfliegt er ist halt gut das ist halt
gut und jetzt versuchen wir das mal das
ladegerät kommt einfach die unten dran
ist magnetisch also die qualität auf dem
ersten album ist echt nice jetzt brauche
ich man auch eben mein macbook um das
oder kann man es irgendwann machen
ich glaube nämlich die ist tatsächlich
lernt haben die gar keinem schreibtisch
hier ist eine beschreibung
ok dann stecken wir da immer rein kann
man hier passt das hat mir gerade zwölf
hunde wie am 14
oder schon später ich habe erstens schon
eine apple watch mit einer verglichen
deswegen bin ich da eigentlich auf den
ganz guten stand wir haben jetzt hier so
diese ganz normalen standard funktionen
die eigentlich jede smart watch
mitbringt habe ich eben ja auch
vorgestellt und das funktioniert ganz
einfach so wir drücken ja einmal drauf
dann geht die an und können dann hier
durch das menü switchen haben wir einmal
einen step zähler also wie viele
schritte man am tag macht und dann einen
kilometerzähler wie weit man rennt und
wird dann noch eine kilokalorien messe
weiß man dass so nennt und hier so ein
heartbeat messer ja und das war es dann
auch schon also also besonders viele
funktionen bringt jetzt natürlich nicht
mit aber das was man braucht und dann
haben wir einen auf die kopfhörer als
kleines extra was ich vorher wirklich
noch nie gesehen habe ich finde dann
wahrscheinlich bei sololäufen anwenden
und weißt du wenn du auflaufen gehst
hast du direkt eine kopfhörer dabei kann
es sein heartbeat messen kannst deine
schritte messen und so weiter
bist du ein ich war gestern und
vorgestern laufen lassen merkt ja ja
deswegen dies galt eigentlich perfekt
für mich dann mache ich mir jetzt mal
darum hat man nicht hast du das lösen
von rätseln
so jetzt habe ich die what i am
handgelenk eis taut mein herzschlag trat
schon gemessen 74 100 kommt das vor
einem greenscreen sowie 94 95
selbst 90 98 100 100 ok 104 105 also was
ist schon normal
ich habe keine pflicht auch nicht naja
ich musste erst mal laden lassen weil
dann wird mir bei uns dem anderen zeugs
hier und natürlich auf den kopfhörern
weil hier ist leider nicht mehr
aufgeladen habe ich mir schon gedacht
okay leute
wir haben die us aufgeladen hat ungefähr
eine dreiviertel stunde gedauert jetzt
ist die komplett aufgeladen und ich habe
die auch schon mit dem handy verbunden
ich habe hier eine app heruntergeladen
die app von dieser uhr war das feuer in
der beschreibung die heißt einfach kkv
funktioniert aber auch wirklich optimal
aber ich kann euch das hier kurz mal
zeigen wir haben wir die verschiedenen
funktionen aufgeführt zum beispiel 35
schritte bin ich heute schon gerannt 0
stunden und 9 minuten geschlafen wegen
pulsmesser und so dann haben wir hier
den pulsmesser den kammern gern mal
gleich starten und hier den blutdruck
dann hab ich grad schon mal gemessen
machen wir gern noch mal damit dass hier
einfach kurz sozusagen einmal überprüft
und dann müsste gleich der wert kommen
von dem ich absolut keine ahnung habe ob
dieser gesund ist ich gehe mal davon aus
weil dort gerade hatte ich 128 10 85
oder so jetzt sind es 114 zu 68 wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie bisschen entspannter
gewesen und jetzt einmal die
herzfrequenz 77 schläge ja das ist
glaube ich ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben
ich mache zum arzt gehen soll oder auch
das okay jetzt aber leute ich muss
wirklich sagen die app natürlich
kostenlos kann man ganz entspannt
runterladen hat sich direkt automatisch
mit der uhr connected die uhrzeit und
das datum wurde und auch automatisch
angepasst hier kann man die szenen die
ich jetzt heute schon mit der uhr
gemacht habe und die distanz die
kilokalorien verbracht habt also das ist
eigentlich alles ganz entspannt möglich
wenn ich jetzt noch mal nach das haben
jetzt schon zum zweiten mal gemacht dann
sollten wir hier genau das haben wir
sogar schon 45 6 also das funktioniert
alles einwandfrei aber leuchtet der
grund warum viele von euch bestimmt
eigentlich haben und warum ich das ding
auch bestellt haben ist wir können
einfach hier auf
flex basierter basis einfach jetzt hier
das dingen aufmachen einer stellt euch
fahren wie wieder die leute gucken wenn
hier
ich habe das sollte am besten nicht zu
sein
im teppich oder hier schon gedanken
jetzt ist der weg dann vielleicht hier
drauf darauf
wir können das hier dann ganz einfach
aufklappen packen die in die ohren
okay das mache ich jetzt gerade auch zum
ersten mal trafen sich dazu ich bin mal
gespannt ob die automatisch jetzt
connected sind allerdings haben wir
einmal die uhr die heißt msa im kmg und
dann noch die kopfhörer die meisten im
17 mann weiter zusammen connecten und
jetzt muss ich einfach nur ich bin
gespannt alte auch die gut sind das wäre
natürlich krass wenn die jetzt auch noch
gut sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich muss sagen es ist ein bisschen
schade man wünscht sich dass die noch
mehr ins ohr gehen aber tun sagt nicht
weil der klang so ein bisschen ja so
entweicht irgendwie weil die nicht nicht
tief genug für dich finde ich ins organ
gilt der was ist jetzt auch nicht
optimal aber ich bin trotzdem sagen das
sind auf jeden fall vernünftige dinge
werfen schon viel viel viel schlechtere
fast alle die wir getestet haben waren
schlechter als die jetzt und ich finde
dann wenn man auch die smart watch dazu
hat also das ist absolut future mäßig
ich feiere es brutal
also dieses produkt ich da er sonst
immer ich verließ alle sachen auch
instagram alex wie heiß ich da könnt ihr
sehr gerne
abchecken normalerweise mache ich das
auch immer das war hätte ich auf jeden
fall selber vorher auch für meine
zukünftigen joggen sessions natürlich
sind die kopfhörer ist nicht so gut wie
die kooperativ sonst benutzer aber ich
bin von der qualität vom gesamt package
das einzige was blöd waren weil die
versandzeit dass das so ähnlich gedauert
hat aber wenn man das erst mal hat ist
es auf jeden fall nice deswegen hat es
mich auch sehr gefreut diesen kleinen
test zu machen also das produkt absolut
geil feiere ich vielleicht muss es eben
abzuschließen wenn man hier in die
einstellung geht hier oben kann man noch
einige weitere sachen einstellen wie zum
beispiel ein bäcker irgendwie so ein
drittel modus das dann fotografiert wird
automatisch das wetter blablabla also
die hat eigentlich alles was man auch
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
dass nur noch unterschreibt der super
gerne bei instagram welche produkte ich
noch bestellen soll ich kann mich
allerdings sagen dass ich viel viel
bestellt habe was zum teil auch schon da
ist da könnt ihr euch übermorgen noch
freuen gibt es schon das nächste video
abonniert den kanal
aber mir auch sehr gern meinen zweikanal
alex v das was vor mir
haut rein